le conseil départemental soutien
d'apprentissage c'est en ce sens que de
nombreux apprentis rejoignent chaque
année si la collectivité
malheureusement pas tous les candidats
qui ont postulé ont été recrutés la
présentait les élus ont décidé donc de
rencontrer tous ces jeunes pour trouver
des solutions
parmi ces solutions de mobilité avec le
cnam qui bénéficie du financement de la
collectivité
ainsi le cas on permet à de nombreux
jeunes diplômés ou non de suivre des
formations notamment en contrat
d'apprentissage policiers que mana
devrait aussi le guen armes qui propose
deux dispositifs en direction des
personnes en recherche d'emploi ou de
formation
le premier permet de répondre
directement des offres d'emploi et le
second facilite la prospection au niveau
national le cloud propose deux
dispositifs soit vous partez sur une
promesse d'embauché en contrat de
travail soit vous partez en rechercher
un pour les dispositifs avec emploi nous
avons régulièrement des opérations de
recrutement dont actuellement vous avez
casino la prospection d'emploi en étudie
votre projet au préalable et donc on
vous accompagne sur une prospection
d'emplois on a une étude de marché par
rapport à votre secteur d'activité et la
région sur laquelle vous partez et
ensuite on valide le projet dont vous
allez sur place pour prospecter le grand
départ pour saxons et pierre c'est pour
bientôt
ces deux jeunes de 19 ans qui n'ont
aucun diplôme ont signé deux contrats
d'apprentissage qui vont leur permettre
de se former et surtout de trouver un
emploi saxon a connu la galère
aujourd'hui son projet movie il sait ce
qu'il veut il compte bien réussir avec
l'aide du cna préparation diplôme ça va
durer à peu près deux ans pour préparer
un bac pro bac pro hôtellerie non
commercialisation restauration la tombe
de mon départ mois de septembre on va
continuer la suite en france à paris
pierre lui a déjà tenté la mobilité seul
un échec dont il tire les conséquences
aujourd'hui ce sont soutenus avec
l'accompagnement que lui proposait
aucune arme fétiche à bouger en mobilité
mais sans l'aide du cnls arabe une
première fois ça n'a pas marché donc je
suis revenu à la réunion je me suis
dirigé vers l'oc normes parce que j'ai
eu une offre qui me plaisait c'était
apprenti boucher
j'ai passé deux entretiens d'embauché
avec deux entreprises différentes dont
le groupe casino et le groupe monoprix
les deux hommes ont accepté j'ai fait
mon choix j'ai choisi monoprix et je
pars pour une durée minimale de deux ans
moi je veux m'installer là-bas
une soixantaine de jeunes étaient
présentes dans l'hémicycle ce sont plus
de la moitié qui ont sollicité un rendez
vous avec les conseillers d'une arme
prochaine étape pour eu des entretiens
avec peut-être à la clé comme free
projets d'avenir